welcome to this video playing cycle
cowboy this is graham awesome Simon
Williams I'm not going from the mainline
mainline classical Dutch not i'm not
saying that this is a fantastic opening
but he is the world leading expert in
that so not not going not going for that
okay he might still play d65 mm-hmm
probably this isn't a very successful
way to play what I'm doing yeah I mean
but ok maybe it is still it is so
satisfactory with you for you probably
play f4 no we are of course why not
let's let's castle no FYI i need to make
sure i get some pressure against you
five he might even castle long in this
position
Bishop d7 looks advisable don't want you
get your porn structure destroy it i
guess ok so maybe here 9c for quincy
forecheck possibly night c4c doing
against this Bishop a 60 I don't know it
looks like a good position i move anyway
aha age three ok but the moment I'm not
threatening to take to take on e5 anyway
so I understand I was surprised also
thought you should play night and I
Bishop d7 avoiding this the structural
damage
as an awkward pin of course i would like
to like to get rid of the pin if
possible nitin like 23 it's not
happening and not helping out the aid I
understand okay so maybe just trying to
double on the D file maybe Knight b6
coming maybe
ok let's let's push him to h5 so that
this is actually a temple ok i was
thinking night a five but maybe this is
not doing anything
that's actually not doing very much
hmm you can also just take it and go to
December why not actually keep it simple
looks weird because it it improves the
spawn structure by brooke d Sapna just
to discern why not if you can show the
only open file you might as well invade
on the 7th ok so what I now need to do
is to just exchange queen so this would
would be excellent some way to do that
or should I just take c7 can just do
that by lately why not it's now rook g7
I guess keeping a look on the self
yeah what do I want want to achieve here
probably rook exchange rook exchange
would be nice roop the eight or maybe
queen queen d success also a move that
would improve my position I can also I
know before before it's really nonsense
no no not that quindi 60 getting rid of
his active piece should be a good idea
after take stakes 'if I've nc6 is
hanging so this looks like a very good
endgame rook c8 rookie 6 not immediately
plus King everyone this is this is a
winning end game I can only need to be
cautious not to to do something very
stupid so is there any count to play
before maybe now but i can i can really
just take this if he goes to 2 here to
d2 I of Luke c5 there's simply nothing
happening can take any 5 and b5
just thinking of any and he still made
stuff they still made happening but I
don't think there is check now after be
six it is yeah I better I better avoid
any stalemates gif gif is king give his
King some space black resigns yeah I'm
not not sure but about all this if he
and I was I mean this is certainly okay
for black definitely I mean he can do
something like this check but I don't
think it is any good I mean have this
kind of stuff it's far too greedy this
is this is perfectly ok I think castles
and now you went with this F for
business so I went Bishop b5 and why not
Bishop d7 essence is just ok for black
not not sure why you need to damage your
pawn structure maybe he was concerned
about this
should be okay for black maybe queen
deform therefore porn is a little bit
irritating it's it's not very much
connected to the rest of the position
but I computer gives it as equals
probably nothing special and here i
don't know i mean this looks this looks
like structurally from a structural
point of view excellent for white very
bad porn structure Queen c4 yeah that's
a good plan how the compound still wants
to play much stronger this this and 94
very strong yeah yeah very strong now I
didn't see that it's much stronger
because it also gets the Queen out of
the coming Bishop g4 pin and from c3
this year they're 390 so it's a securely
protected this is also just good for
lighter maybe this is so this is more
tenacious twosome Queen before yeah but
okay it's just good for white what can
you do having that the only open file
must must be worth something here the
compass assistance again playing a very
strong okay yeah there this is very very
strong now the rook must retreat
somewhere I don't know here or something
and then I'm getting in there one
possible line it does not need to go
compounds to go here covering tampering
g7 but it's a fantastic position for
white something like this but okay I
think I always kept a big advantage
which is what what counts you cannot
expect perfect play
Abby for us even stronger it seems but
okay I wanted to get the Queen's Own
when this end Cambyses flat-out winning
yeah not much to look at that it's just
a totally winning weekend care okay
thanks for watching